quizás justamente es eso que pongas char
de huachi por casi seguro de que su
juventud y su fuerza y su experiencia
también en esta carrera le iban a dar la
tercera victoria sin embargo en la etapa
número 11 los saltos en este puerto de
grano no apareció el danés bien llegaron
tura de mar que comenzó en dinamarca y
le arrebató ese mayo amarillo esa
camiseta amarilla y no la soltó hasta el
final hay que decir que para gastar
siempre intentó quitársela pero sin
llegar reaccionó siempre con la misma
fuerza que el joven no para gastar puede
ser porque los dos están muy por encima
quizás en condiciones físicas y en el
profesionalismo arriba una bicicleta que
los otros corredores así que eso le dio
la victoria bien llegar y no hay que
dejar de lado su equipo efectivamente el
rumbo o bismark yo estuve en la etapa
pirenaica la última nota cam y
justamente ahí se vio como el belga van
a él le ayudó desde el comienzo de la
carrera y hasta el final cuando yo vio
que era seguro que él iba a ganar lo
dejó lo mismo sus el estadounidense
estuvo mucho mejor acompañado bien
llegar a que lo que estuvo o para gastar
y eso se notó también y lo que ahora la
duda que queda justamente es si el belga
van a er va a intentar alguna vez el
mismo ganar para él el tour de francia
el de casio un excelente compañero él
decía ayer que en realidad lo que él
hacía era un día o una cosa es una etapa
pero que todos los días estar allí al
frente para él no sería posible se
quitaba méritos de manera muy humilde
[Música]